so we're going to start with some
breaking news out of germany the first
ever conviction for crimes against
humanity for a former syrian government
official a german court has sentenced
anwar raslan to life in prison he was
head of an intelligence office in a
damascus detention center prosecutors
say that is where he oversaw the killing
of 58 people and the torture of 4 000
others this was in 2011 2012 rasan's
trial began two years ago after he
defected
and sought asylum in germany
with us from brussels to talk about this
eric vitti who is a senior policy
officer at the open society justice
initiative
uh let's just talk about the verdict
first of all the fact that
and it sounds trite but it does bring
some level of accountability or at least
the start of some level of
accountability
it does and for some victims of
systematic torture in bashar al-assad
syria this will bring some measure of
justice some measure of solace
so
let's go through the the process of how
this became a
german trial i mentioned there before
that he what was it he defected and
sought asylum in germany
he did and uh germany
has
the ability to prosecute crimes that
crimes against humanity and war crimes
that happen outside of its territory
under the principle of universal
jurisdiction it's called
um is that a uniquely german thing sorry
to interrupt you just quickly
it's not uniquely german but germany has
really been leading the way in
exercising you know universal
jurisdiction
um there have been other cases in france
sweden and the netherlands gotcha okay
sorry to introduce carry on with what
you were saying
no so uh the information came to uh the
attention of the authorities um anmar
ruslan was was recognized uh by some of
the victims of torture at branch 251
um where he led intelligence operations
and really oversaw the regime of torture
in that
intelligence branch
and once that information was brought to
the authorities there was a tremendous
effort by syrian
activists and civil society to collect
information
and bring that to prosecutors
with the help of some international ngos
and this trial really validates those
efforts uh over over several years now
um
to
to hold
one
well really the most senior official to
date uh from the government of bashar
al-assad um to account for
the torture of
over four thousand people gosh um are
there others in the sites of the court
as well
there are other complaints
in germany
and there are
other cases in development in other
countries
you know for for different crimes
some of those cases also relate to
the systematic torture uh in detention
facilities
um some relate to chemical weapons use
uh
sexual violence and other crimes
eric would you really appreciate your
time today fast-moving story or breaking
story glad you could join us for that
thank you so much